hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer
i provide content for new and aspiring
software engineers
and today we're going to be talking
about the best way
to optimize your github so that when a
recruiter goes on to it
when a company goes on to it it is the
best
it can be it is eye-catching yet
really showcases your talent and
really shows them that okay this this
might be the person we need to call for
an interview let's get them in the
office and see
what they're about so let's get
to it so here is the github
that will serve as our model for this
demonstration
we are going to focus on four primary
parts we're going to focus
on this intro area you see right here
we're going to focus on the left of it
we're also going to focus
on the pinned section and then our
contributions
area so starting with
this right here big text
section this is something that i
actually did not know was
possible until i saw other people's
readmes and githubs
and i was like oh wow like i want
that that's very eye-catching it's
really cool and it makes
you know github and profiles just more
exciting
so we want to provide whoever comes onto
our github
profile with some type of introduction
to ourselves let's think about applying
to jobs
and recruiters going onto our github
which many of them
do so we want to provide them with a
quick introduction
and what you focus on in terms of your
engineering here
i say that my focus is on either front
end or full stack
development and my projects are
reflections of my interests and passions
and i like to maintain
a sleek modern design despite how you
know
complicated the apps themselves may be
this is very important because yes your
resume is there to
show your skills and your experiences
but it also
makes it the recruiter's job to kind of
read between the lines
and say okay so it looks like their
focus is x y and z
and you know because this is what they
listed their skills and and all that
but by you taking this opportunity to in
your github and
really in all your other profiles
linkedin profile and
all of that you can say look
no reading between the lines like i am
the person
for front-end engineering this is my
focus this is what i do in my free time
i am your girl i am your guy i am your
person so really just take that
opportunity to do that
here then i put a little bit of
my background into the same section and
so here
i put that i'm a graduate from a
four-year
university with a finance and accounting
degree and i state a little bit
why i switched to software engineering
saying that i just
wasn't very fulfilled despite my
interest in the subject matter
and you know after doing this one task
of automation for my team i realized i
was in the wrong field because it was
the best
working day ever so that ladies and
gents
is when i knew i was in the wrong field
and now here
i am it's okay to be a little bit more
casual with this it's okay
to you know let your hair down and show
these recruiters and other people
viewing your page
just you know what your personality is
like and so that's what i like to do
here like emojis and just being you know
really kind of animated in some parts
but also showing that i am competent
and you know would be a great member to
their team and then i put a contact me
blurb right here saying
feel free to contact me via linkedin or
email
and so before we get to this next
section over here
let me show you all how to actually add
this to your github because that is
something that i did not know how to
do so we go into repositories
click there select new on the right
and then with repository name
make it whatever your username is and so
you see
on the left my username is the black
female engineer
make your repo name the exact same thing
copying the casing and
everything it has to be an exact match
and so well mine already exists because
you saw
the section already but you see when i
do that
this little thing pops up that says you
found a secret
the black female engineer slash the
black female engineer
is a special repository that you can use
to add a readme
to your github profile make sure it's
public and initialize it with a readme
to get started
so we scroll down make sure
public is selected and then click
add a readme file then after
make after you make sure that that is
checked then you
click create repository i can't because
mine is already created
but you then create repository
so now let's go back to my page
and i'm going to show you what it looks
like when you create it so when you
create
your repository what will happen
is let me click edit you are sent
to where you can put in the information
you
want really you can put in images you
can put in
the texture of the emojis etc you
get these large headers by putting three
hashtags first
and then anything past the hashtags is
text or you know just like the regular
uh body text but you can also put in
images in here and those will show up
you can add to the emojis etc and then
when you're ready you just say commit
directly to the main branch and then
commit changes and click that
and then you should see it just pop up
right front and center on your github
profile and so this is just yeah
something super fun to add and
i don't know it makes me happy maybe i'm
just you know a nerd for these kinds of
things
but it makes me really happy to see
so next on the left side of our github
is where our more general information
um is so let's click
edit profile because this is really how
all of this happens
so if we could click edit profile that
is where you can
create just a quick little blurb here
and so you know software engineer with
additional experience in x y and z
looking to use my skills in front of
development and user focus development
then you can put where you are currently
working
i had just put flat iron school because
i was a student of flat iron school
they can put your location this is
something you can
um choose to opt out of to be honest
what i've seen
um and you know this may be different
experiences for different people
but what i have seen is certain jobs
maybe um
putting certain applications to the side
because they
see that they're in the location where
they are not based and they don't want
to pay for relocation
and so some people will choose to not
put their location
but i had my location on there you can
put your
email putting your email is kind of
tricky i'll show you that in a second
but then you can link anything you want
as well you can link your linkedin so
you know whatever your linkedin url is
so
linkedin.com that's the black female
engineer that is you know not my
linkedin
but you can put your linkedin you can
also link wherever your portfolio
site is you can click link it here or
a great idea is to also link it right
here because again it's very hard to
miss
right here then you can also link in a
twitter
so let me show you how to
put in your email oh yeah it was in the
settings
so if you go to settings so if you click
email settings that is where you can add
your new email
and then once your new email is verified
then
you go in here and select that new
verified email
i'm not going to click this because it
has personal very very personal
information
but trust me it'll all make sense once
you click this button
so let's go back to our personal profile
so section three the pin section now
this is very
important the pins section is where we
want to put in
all of our projects that we want to say
yo
yo recruiter over there
look at these things that i did and so
they can see
okay project number two front end
and then see you know the
walkthrough the readme table of contents
i always created walkthrough videos for
each specific app i created because
it's very rare that a person will really
take the time to
parse through all code but instead will
watch a video of what you created and so
this is how
all of my apps look
in their readme and so i pinned all the
apps i wanted them to really focus on
here
um or not really not the apps but the
repos and so
each app is like a row because i had the
front end of the back end
in two different repos all the time it's
just very important to have
a separation of concern that way and so
not having your front end back end in
the same exact
app or same exact repo is very important
now the front and back and front and
back and front end back end that is how
i worked so how do we do this we click
customize your pins so if you click
customize your pins you get access to
every single one of your repos and so
you can only
pick six yes that's up to six public
repositories
and so click on those the ones you want
it doesn't have to be six it can be two
it can be one
i like to aim for at least three
but you know if you're new you don't
don't be out here putting
repos to terrible projects just because
you're trying to
add more things just wait you know be
patient and
you'll get to that number that you want
so then after you finish you know
selecting everything
and whatnot click save pins
and then they would show up in the pin
section
you can then move them the way you want
and so i like things to be easy to
follow and so i liked all the front end
stuff being in one section
and then all the back and stuff being in
the other section
and making each row its own project so
that's the way i decided
to go at it now finally
the contributions now no one dragged me
okay like
i got a job like right around here and
so i
kind of fell off in my personal github
um commits but while i
was you know in school and looking for
a job i really really tried to make sure
i kept
things um as green as possible making
sure i
at least coded or at least committed
once
every like two days but of course you
know sometimes long weekends would
happen
and you know you know things things
happen but
but yes trying to make sure that whoever
comes
to my github sees that i
am serious about this that i am not just
doing this for kicks
and for giggles but i'm doing this to
actually
make a true career shift and be a true
engineer
so if you see everything from you know
may back
i did not know github even existed i did
not know what it was
i had no idea but that is um
in this period when i started to learn
to code and then
really started making sure all of my
projects
were being pushed up to github to really
make sure that
my activity was being stored because
even in this
may section i was still producing
projects i was still coding but
i didn't know the importance of tracking
that activity and that progress
through github and so or some type of
version
control app and so
that is why there's really nothing from
here on back
but yes started school and then really
started making sure
i was committing every day and so
that is very very important because you
can say in your interview that
hey i have a true passion for coding and
i code all the time
but then if this you know recruiter
pulls up
this your github and sees
this section right here but that is
all your sections like something's not
adding up
that is not okay and you want to really
make sure
that you are given you are giving these
recruiters and these companies every
reason to believe what you are saying
and every reason
to trust that you're a passionate and
trust that you are determined
and show them that you are the person to
hire
so there we have it everybody my tips
as to how to best optimize your github
specifically while you're onto the job
hunt
so you can really just increase your
odds of getting that phone call
that you got the job or you know at
least you know
a phone call for a round one interview
if you'd like me to get more in depth
into the
readme or anything like that please let
me know in the comments i like to make
sure i'm tailoring my
content to something that you all want
to see
so please let me know but thank you so
much everybody and i'll see
y'all later bye y'all